politicians should be on social media
because it's also their way of
connecting with people
and they certainly have a right to free
speech so i don't think it was easy
for meta to decide whether mr trump
should be taken down or not and we
actually also touched upon in our
decision that trump should not be taken
down because he was saying falsehoods
about the election we only said that it
was right to take mr trump down because
he was inciting violence
[Music]
hello and welcome
billions of posts from billions of users
political social and financial power
bigger than some nation states so how do
you oversee facebook that job falls to
the relatively new facebook oversight
board dubbed the social network's
so-called supreme court and my guest
today is its coacher heller torning
schmidt who was denmark's first female
prime minister she led the centre-left
social democrats party in a coalition
and held that post for four years until
2016. now she's helping to oversee the
tech titan which operates under the
parent company meta and also owns
whatsapp and instagram so can it really
be held to account even by former world
leaders professors charity bosses and
nobel laureates at a time when the
social network business can block a u.s
president and as it tries to curb covert
misinformation arguably it's a more
important role than ever hell is warning
schmidt welcome thank you very much
well we'll get to that role shortly but
i wanted to just come to something which
i find fascinating about you
you were 48 when you left the biggest
job of your life it's actually very
interesting because i i think that us
prime ministers we become younger and
younger
and that also means that we leave
earlier many former prime ministers they
actually yeah died on the job but we are
a generation of politicians that came
into politics quite early
and also leaving quite early and that
means that i was just before 50
and had just to shake my head a bit and
find out what's what's there for me for
the rest of my working life
and was extremely fortunate that i got
in contact with say the children
international here in london
and started talking to them because they
needed a new ceo and i took over that
role and was so happy to start a new
chapter with something so meaningful as
working for children all over the world
can you remember that the day after you
ended being prime minister i mean did
you just get your jogging bottoms on you
slippers you slob about what do you do
it is so weird to stop being prime
minister and i think there's nothing
that compares to that you you just your
whole life changes and i remember very
clearly
coming in hugging my chauffeurs and my
the police that had been helping me all
the way through hugged them goodbye
outside my house walked in closed the
door behind me
and quiet
just quiet no one phones you the office
the party you're used to people
connecting and talking to you all the
time and stuff happening all the time
and it was just quiet so i remember that
quiet it was a tree not like
a depression but a little bit of a
situation where you're not quite sure
how you live in this life without all
the buzz that was around you uh but i
watched game of thrones for
four months i got one okay no not really
i got our bikes repaired so i could bike
round copenhagen there are so many
things i hadn't done on my bike or just
walking around copenhagen that was my
way of transitioning into just being a
normal person again so you mentioned
about becoming the chief executive of
save the children international that
came to an end and your next role which
is as i was just saying in my
introduction such an important and
pivotal moment to have such a role is
co-chair of this uh facebook oversight
board i just wanted to ask first of all
who asked you to do it and why did you
want to do it
well we all know that social media has
come up as hell and has for a long long
time been
very unregulated and basically what we
saw was that the ultimate decisions
about what content stays up on social
media or gets removed is taken by the
social media company companies
themselves and ultimately mark
zuckerberg
and somehow that doesn't feel right we
need probably more regulation on social
media but it also seemed a better way of
doing it that facebook was actually
outsourcing to an independent body
how their content should be reviewed and
so so basically the reason why i took on
the role is because i consider the
oversight board independent
facebook has to listen to our decisions
they have to follow our decisions and we
also have this opportunity to give them
advice or recommendations of what they
should do on social media and that goes
both for for facebook and for instagram
so unless we have been promised complete
independence and that they would
actually abide by our decisions and
follow our decisions i would not have
done it so it's basically facebook's
leadership asking me to do this and we
look very very carefully into whether
this would be an institution that would
be have that complete independence let's
definitely come to the and test the
independence in just a moment if we can
but are you comfortable with the amount
of power meta has overseeing facebook
instagram watson uh yes and no i mean i
think social media has been too
unregulated for too many years and uh
obviously the oversight board is not
dealing with everything meta there'll be
tax discussions and other discussions
anti-trust discussions that we are not
dealing with we are dealing with content
but there is absolutely no doubt that
until we started our work
meta was left too alone in terms of
deciding on content
whether content should stay up or get
removed making their own rules as they
went along the transparency was missing
it still is and that is why we need
regulation and we need an oversight
board what do you say to those who are
concerned that you are funded by
facebook to police facebook
well facebook cannot interfere in any of
our decisions
they have to live with our decisions
when we decided on the case with
regarding trump for example they had to
follow our decisions and i don't talk to
none of us talk to facebook about how we
should decide anything so it's up to
each and everyone to decide do they
think that's independence i don't take
any orders from facebook you don't take
any orders but you can't necessarily
know what they're not telling you and no
and for the world you know the
whistleblower francis houghton came to
people's attention she came and spoke
aloud for instance about that
high-profile facebook users got to
follow different rules and receive
special treatment i mean how can you
trust facebook after that do you have to
trust facebook to tell you no we have to
find a retrust on facebook after that
because for example on the cross checks
that haugen was talking about
there's no doubt that we didn't know
enough about that which we have
criticized uh meta for not telling us
sufficiently clear about these cross
checks also when we asked about it we
didn't get sufficient answers so so this
is something we're going to follow up on
and i think just the fact we have
existed for a little more than a year
now has shed some light on the lack of
transparency
the cross checks the fact they don't
talk about these things in public and
other aspects of uh the lack of
transparency with with meta so i do
think that you're annoyed when you saw
what francis had to say i was i yes some
of it yes i was annoyed when i found out
that the cross checks that we had been
asking meta about they had not
given
a fulfilling answer to our questions
what do you mean crosstalk sorry cross
checks is what they do with these how
high profiled individuals there has an
account where there seemed to be special
uh rules for high-profile individuals
and you hadn't been told about it we had
not been told about it and when we asked
in the context of the trump case that we
looked at yes they didn't give us a
fulfilling answer which we have
criticized also publicly so this i think
actually underlines that you're right we
don't know what we don't know but
gradually when
meta is forced to open up more to us and
then also a whistleblower to the yeah
but that's absolutely but that's why
it's good to have whistleblowers but i
also think our role here is to keep
asking those questions we've also asked
francis haugen afterwards we had
interviews with her because we invited
her
we have spoken to her yeah and we are
probably going to speak to her again
so we have spoken to her in the
oversight board to get even more
information and we will continue to talk
to anyone who's got anything to say
about meta that we think will help us in
our work and learn from that and feed
that back to facebook knowing that you
have been mislead
i wouldn't call it mislead i think
that's that's your word not mine okay so
what would you they didn't tell us the
full the full picture they didn't give
us a full picture of knowing that you've
been left in the dark yeah over some
things is that a better
way of putting it it's details
how do you then trust facebook do you
trust facebook i think facebook should
be much more transparent with the
oversight board but also with the
general public which is actually more
important
and i believe that the work that i'm
part of in the oversight board will have
that
do you trust them you're the co-chair of
the board yeah i trust facebook that
they give us the information that we're
asking for
even though they haven't
i don't think they were completely aware
that they didn't um but but that's a
different question and we have
criticized them for for it and there
will be other things in why why do you
think they left you in the dark
i don't know you have to ask meta that
but i think the most important you ask
me
do i trust facebook i trust facebook
generally but that doesn't mean that
they will in this instance but also
further on down the line there will be
more areas where we will criticize
matter
we criticize mata every time we take a
decision on anything we have already
issued more than 80 recommendations for
for meta and we will keep doing that
we push them hard on some of these
issues so i don't need to trust meta
completely i need to trust that they
give us the information and they answer
our questions truthfully which i do but
i think that that will actually result
in matter treating their users better
and being more transparent in general
should mark zuckerberg still be in
charge i think it would be very wrong of
me as a co-chair of the oversight board
to start having opinions about who leads
meta
so i will refrain from from getting into
that discussion i will not do that uh
because i think you'll you'll mix up
what the role of the oversight board is
okay which is to look at the content i
get i just wondered if you if you did
have a view i know you've got a lot of
opinions yes i've got a lot of people
what it is i'll tell you something
people do have a huge opinion about you
mentioned it briefly but i want to just
get a little bit more into the detail uh
almost a year ago to the day really
facebook decided to suspend president
trump for sharing a video of his support
to his supporters some of his supporters
for storming the capital um you upheld
that view that decision to suspend him
indefinitely but not permanently is that
right
it was a very interesting
situation where facebook had decided to
uh now met her decided to remove trump
from the platforms based
on the fact that he was inciting
violence and they asked us whether that
was the oversight board whether that was
the right decision that was one or not
one of the decisions where user
complains it was actually meta asking
the oversight board what we thought
about this
and we agreed with meta that they it it
was okay to remove mr trump on the basis
that he was inciting violence but we
disagreed with the sanction that meta
had given so we asked the max to go back
and find a new sanction
for mr trump so it became
more case about
meta and an arbitrary
sanction than it was about mr trump so
it was sorting out the system as well as
taking a view yes on that yes i
understand that but
some people did view that as
anti-democratic you know
75 million people voted for it yeah and
facebook is in this situation
where it offers everybody the platform
and i suppose what would you say to
those people who say he has a right to
be on facebook the most positive thing
about social media
is that and we forget that sometimes
when we discuss social media is that
people have been
given voice where they otherwise would
not have a voice agency and so many
people can actually
gather
make groups
create demonstrations be together on
social media where before they didn't
have a voice so that's the most amazing
thing about social media and of course
politicians should be on social media
because it's also their way of
connecting with people
and they have certainly have a right to
free speech so i don't think it was easy
for meta to decide whether mr trump
should be taken down or not and we
actually also touch upon in our decision
that trump should not be taken down
because he was saying falsehoods about
the elections that he was not speaking
the truth about the election result we
only said that it was right to take mr
trump down because he was inciting
violence
and within facebook's own rules you
can't incite violence i've got the right
to speak but i don't have the right to
speak if i'm actually inciting violence
against you or anyone else so that is
where we have to draw a balance and i we
thought that meta did that the right
place um but of course mr trump has the
right to be on on facebook and instagram
if he does not incite violence when's he
coming back then i don't know you have
to ask meta that is there a date i i
don't know they've they've given him uh
i think gave him two years or something
like that so you have to ask me to we'll
be back in time potentially for another
run at the white house we'll see that's
going to matter we we will see and then
you'll look at it of course that's part
of the of how it works as we're learning
is facebook a platform or a publisher
it's a platform in my view because it
sounds terribly like a publisher do you
think as an editor in the way you just
described that view of of donald trump i
don't think so because anyone who
creates a platform where people can can
be part of it they have created some
rules so i do think it's it's good they
have the community standards they're
actually really good the community
standards that they have the problem is
that they're not always followed but the
community standards are are good uh so
you said that decision sorry to
interrupt but you said that decision
about donald trump just to go back to to
how you put it
was not made by the community it was
actually by meta it wasn't by you know
users coming forward so that to me you
know as a journalist brings to mind an
editor sitting in a room saying
well i don't i don't think that's okay
for us to publish yeah but i i this is a
key tension that has been about facebook
for a long time and of course if it
admitted to being a publisher it would
be subject to very different rules yes
so you don't accept that
characterization i don't think uh meta
is a publisher i don't think they see
themselves as a publisher and they are
taking it and i would also question
whether they should they are which they
should should do and i think we also
have to find a new way of seeing that
that's why there's no doubt we need
regulation very much like what we have
you sound like editors you're bored you
said you only look at content i mean
yeah yeah yeah
where does it tip over into not into
being a platform and not being a
publisher what keeps well i think we're
well we're well past the point where you
can just be a platform because you have
to have rules because otherwise it just
goes crazy you will have you have to
take responsibility for what's being
published
more or less yeah you have to take some
response but doesn't matter that doesn't
make you a publisher in the old uh
understanding of the word and that
facebook or meta having its cake and
eating it
i don't think so i think they are
completely entitled to have uh
their standards for what they want for
on their platform regulators are of
course uh
entitled to now regulate the area i
think we also have to quite ask the
question
do we want
social media to be
a publisher no but that's the whole
point a lot of people don't which is why
they want donald trump back on facebook
which i think is a fair point of view
but do we do we want one more
editor but do we want social media to
then be you could put anything on it but
the laws haven't kept the pace so if you
look at the law governing this the u.s
law um this section 230 excuse me uh
state social media companies shouldn't
be responsible for information produced
by someone else which means the user can
publish what they want and that facebook
isn't liable
so which is it you know you sort of
facebook is being liable sometimes and
isn't other times it's focusing but i
think what you're asking is really
underlining that we need regulation but
also underlining that you can't take
social media which exists in all shapes
and sizes in many different countries
all over the world
and squeeze it in to a regulation that
was for uh
yeah previous and other centuries
outlets do you come down on the side
broadly taking a step back coming away
from the detail that social media is a
force for good i do actually
and i think we sometimes forget it
because people are asking really really
harsh questions and demanding more
transparency and and criticizing meta
and social media and twitter and other
companies and fairly so but i think we
sometimes forget would we like to go
back to a world where we didn't have
social media
where we couldn't connect with each
other on on whatsapp for example or
communicate with each other get in
contact with each other and
also
being that when i was ceo save the
children international i met so many
people
across the world in refugee camps and
women who want to organize
labor organize or organize for micro
banking or whatever
and they could not do these things
without being able to connect via social
media black lives matter me too movement
i could go on of course that would exist
and there were movements before social
media but when you wait up i do think
that social media is a force for good
but
we're not there yet i wonder are you
grateful you didn't grow up with social
media well i think no i'm
i love my childhood and i like the
simplicity of my childhood i really did
but i also think when you look at young
people today i have two kids we have two
kids they are 20 25 and 22.
honestly i think they're they know more
about the world they're cleverer they
are better than we were we also have an
individual responsibility as parents to
bring our children up but also
children growing up to teach them how to
be
people
in the world that we have now so i don't
i think we must be very very careful not
to paint this in black and white and say
everything was just better i know that's
what you're doing everything was better
in the old days because there's so many
good things particularly for
for for people perhaps more marginalized
people in the rest of the world being
heard
that has come of social media and i i've
met so many people who finally has a
voice because of social media and we
must be careful not only to judge this
by the narrow lens in a western nordic
world because social media is much much
bigger than that and also i mean just to
say you know
the the societal ills that come out on
social media were not created by social
media
it's a platform to see them in a
different way as well but i was just
going to ask you about something else as
we our time together sort of comes to an
end and it was about
uh joylessness and joy because some feel
taking it from the perspective i am at
the western perspective i recognize that
that the internet certainly did used to
be a bit more fun you know you could
share some jokes i mean you still can
obviously but but people sort of allowed
each other to to say things a bit
tongue-in-cheek a bit sarcastic and i
was just looking back um and you took a
selfie when you were prime minister you
know what i'm going to be saying yeah
but for everyone else and um you were at
nelson mandela's memorial you were a
prime minister and on one side was
barack obama and what the other side was
david cameron and if i was you i'd also
be thinking this is an interesting
selfie in the days before social
distancing so you're crowding you have a
selfie and some said you know this is
not what you should be doing at a
memorial and and actually you responded
saying you know we're we're people we
are people and it was a joyful occasion
in many ways it was a it was a very
joyful occasion it was a memorial but it
was at a sports stadium uh and the south
african like there was strom's music
that was singing it was quite a a joyous
moment and almost a celebration of his
life of his life yeah we sat in the
corner all the head states of government
and david cameron sort of muscled in
where i was sitting which was uh close
to obama we had a nice time everyone was
laughing and uh
and i had not taken selfies of these
days this was my first selfie the first
selfie was the president of america and
i think there and the word actually came
into the dictionary that year uh because
it became so famous and i just thought
this is this is where you take selfies
so i just learned to take selfies from
my oldest daughter quite an impressive
first selfie it's good isn't it
depending on your politics it's it's not
very good i'm the only one who looks
good in that self is actually me and uh
so
but it's a it's actually uh it was fun
but people did criticize it because they
thought it wasn't serious uh and it
certainly wasn't serious and
it was it was interesting to um
to see that we were just three people in
the moment i said oh that's good to try
this and it was like a new thing back
then it sounded like david cameron
really tried to get in
with barack obama it was quite funny
because michelle obama was just on the
side if i remember correctly of the
image that was taken of you taking it
yeah looking um you know not in the
picture just quite quite stern straight
ahead it was never published the selfie
i don't think no i've got it it's on my
phone have you have you framed it i have
actually published i wrote a book in no
i haven't framed it uh i wrote a book um
in denmark in danish uh and it is
actually in there it's in that it's in
there i've seen the light okay i hadn't
i hadn't seen that but i suppose just
just really to get your take around that
which is that you know there's a lot of
hate people don't necessarily see
politicians as people and i just wonder
now you're not one anymore you're still
married to one but certainly you're not
a world leader anymore do you think it's
at our peril that we don't see our
leaders as people
yeah i think it is and i i always just
want people to come down a little bit
because we are all people and we haven't
got a private life i'm not talking about
being soft on politicians and not
criticizing
for them when they do things and and
i've been criticized a lot and prime
minister has been criticized a lot so
that happens
but maybe if we all calm down a little
bit also on social media we would just
have we would just be nicer and i think
the rule should be that we try to treat
people on social media like we would
talk to each other when we met and
people are very polite to each other
when they meet when they stand the queue
together when they take the tube
whatever
and perhaps we should try and take a
little bit of that politeness into
social media and the world would
actually be a better place
hello tony schmidt thank you thank you
so much for having me and thank you so
much for being with us until we meet
again mask up stay safe and goodbye
[Music]
you